[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter fairy today
we're going to be discussing the
recently announced HBO Harry Potter TV
series for those who live under a rock
the announcement of a new Harry Potter
HBO series made headlines all around the
world this week following speculation in
early April Warner Bros Discovery
finally put the rumors to rest on April
12th by confirming their plans for a
brand new Harry Potter series based on
the best-selling novels this
announcement occurred during a
presentation to press and investors we
are delighted to give audiences the
opportunity to discover Hogwarts in a
whole new way said HBO CEO Casey bloys
in the statement Harry Potter is a
cultural phenomenon and it's clear there
is such an enduring love and thirst for
The Wizarding World each season will be
authentic to the original books and
bring Harry Potter and these incredible
Adventures to new audiences around the
world while the Original Classic and
beloved films will remain at the core of
the franchise and available to watch
globally along with the announcement
came a teaser trailer posted to HBO's
official Twitter including the words
your Hogwarts letter is here Max has
ordered the first ever hashtag Harry
Potter scripted television series a
faithful adaptation of the iconic books
hashtag streamon Max and while I'm
excited about the new show there does
seem to be one question that keeps
re-entering my mind who's going to be in
it part of this will depend entirely on
what direction the show takes if the
show does in fact Deep dive into each of
the books as has been reported then
there are certainly going to be a lot of
big shoes to fill however if they decide
to give us a new perspective of The
Wizarding World and introduce a
multitude of new main characters that
are sprinkled in amongst known
characters then I'd imagine casting
would come a lot easier from the sounds
of things is probably going to be more
in line with the former and that's why
today I'm going to be recasting Harry
Potter for 2023 assuming that the series
will start with the first book the
Philosopher's Stone let's start there
and recast some of the main characters
from the first installment in this
series let's dive into it Harry Potter
Harry Potter the main protagonist from
the Harry Potter series and the famous
boy who lived is the driving force of
the Harry Potter movies without him the
film ceased to exist and that's why I
can say with conviction that the casting
of Harry is crucial to the success of
the reboot for the most part we're
looking at the Wizarding World through
the lens of Harry a young boy that
discovers his magical Heritage quite
late in life and has to undergo the
trials and tribulations of a newcomer
entering the Wizarding World whoever
takes on the role of Harry will have to
have an incredibly strong emotional
range the other main consideration when
recasting Harry is that whoever reprises
the role will be instantly compared to
Daniel Radcliffe unfair as it may be
then this will inevitably happen so I
think it may be best to cast a
relatively unknown or fresh actor that
has a clean slate if the announcements
are anything to go by the proposed show
is going to have a lot of Seasons which
of course means that we'll witness the
actors growing up first hand starting
from a blank canvas seems like the best
option here even if it may seem like a
bit of a gamble after all it seemed to
work out pretty well for The Originals
Hermione and Ron bearing what I've just
said in mind I think that this new actor
thing would also apply to Hermione Ron
and wellm just about every child actor
Hogwarts student that's meant to take
place in the series hiring lesser-known
actors and allowing them to blossom into
the roles seems like the best course of
action it won't be easy to find a Nema
Watson or a Rupert Grint but nobody said
remaking Harry Potter would be easy the
same cannot be said however for the
adult actors if the Harry Potter films
are anything to go by then an
illustrious cast of respected British
actors and actresses can certainly Do no
harm to a Film Production the Alan
rickmans the brave fines the John hurts
and the Maggie Smiths and their existing
acting accolades were all pivotal and
enduring the success of the Harry Potter
films Hagrid Hogwarts keeper of keys and
grounds Ruby's hangaret is a beloved
character from the Harry Potter series a
half giant with a heart of gold and a
deep love for all creatures great and
small but the recent passing of Robbie
Coltrane who played Hagrid over the
course of the Harry Potter films it
brings a somber element to Hagrid's
recasting one thing to hold on to
however is that I imagine Robbie
Coltrane himself would be supportive of
Hagrid's Legacy being continued as far
as recasting the first person that comes
to my mind is Greg Draven who does an
expert impersonation of Hagrid and
actually portrayed Hagrid in the magical
creatures motorbike Adventure ride I was
familiarized with Greg when some friends
of mine bought me one of his cameos for
my birthday the best part Greg knew
would be calm train at the kitchen smash
the Roll Another potential candidate for
Hagrid could be Nick Frost British actor
writer and comedian who's perhaps best
known for his work with director Edgar
Wright and actor Simon Pegg he's a warm
actor with a good sense of comedic
timing and a big heart but one of the
detractors for me is that he doesn't
appear to have quite the same calm
demeanor as Coltrane often coming across
as a bit manic another viable option is
Mark Addy an English actor best known
for his role as Dave in the full monty
and King Robert Baratheon in Game of
Thrones Dumbledore Albus Dumbledore's
Hogwarts Headmaster and the most
powerful wizard in The Wizarding World
who was originally played by actor
Richard Harris but after Harris
tragically passed away in 2002 the role
was reprized by actor Michael Gambon
Michael Gambon is still around and I
certainly wouldn't complain if he
reprized the role but I expect that
won't happen although I suspect there
may be a strong Temptation from Warner
Bros to cast Jude Law who played Albus
Dumbledore in Fantastic Beasts suspect
that law is still too young for the role
one pick for Dumbledore that is all
floating around online was Brian Cox one
of the stars of HBO's hit show
succession Cox is a 75 year old
classically trained Shakespearean actor
with an incredibly wide range in terms
of acting ability he's got the right
look and I think he's about the right
age adding Brian Cox to the cast would
lengthen the long list of existing
Shakespearean actors in Harry Potter
which includes Ray fines Alan Rickman
Maggie Smith Kenneth Branagh and Imelda
Staunton to name a few given Cox's
proximity to HBO and his Scottish
Heritage I think he'd be a great pick
it's ever a Snape was every Snape
potions Master Tormentor of Harry and
Lily lover was one of the most iconic
gray characters in all the film and was
expertly played by the late Alan Rickman
Snape is my favorite character in Harry
Potter so this is a tough one for me to
move past but in the interest of
producing the best possible Harry Potter
remake I still want to give it some real
thought
the name that I've seen everywhere thus
far is Adam Driver which from a voice
looks an age standpoint would actually
fit the 32 year old Severus Snape that's
his age in Harry's first year quite well
the only problem is that Adam Driver
isn't British and would have to see some
really good examples of his voice work
to make any further comments on his
casting until I've heard his accent I
can't confidently say that he'd work in
the role the next option could be
Benedict's Cumberbatch he's Loosely the
right age he's an amazing actor he's got
the right range and he even has a
demonstrated ability to do Snape's voice
as shown on Jimmy Fallon another option
to consider is Tom Hiddleston who
notably plays Loki in The Avengers films
there are some other names that come to
my mind like Tim Roth Rufus Sewell and
maybe even Christopher Eccleston but I
think they may all just be a bit too old
to portray the 32 year old Snape at this
point at least the creators of the show
want to stay true to the books in the
case of Alan Rickman they made an
exception in with just a few of those
main actors out of the way I'm going to
stop myself and ruminate some more on my
decisions I'm curious to see what you
all think and Who You'd cast in these
iconic roles please leave a comment down
below with what you think about the show
what you think about my casting
decisions and well anything else you
want to comment about until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live